It's just a lot of very exciting
AI features that we already
infused into Microsoft
products like Office 365.
But at Microsoft we also want
to make sure that we can offer
this kind of incredible AI
experiences to our partners and
developers.
How can we help them to
build just as exciting
AI applications?
I've talked earlier about AI
platforms and other things.
I also want to mention that
in a key to making greater AI
apps is the data.
That's where actually Microsoft
is in a unique position to
offer our partners, developers,
and the partners to help them to
build AI applications by
providing them Microsoft Graphs.
It includes an word knowledge
graph like what you can get from
Bing and LinkedIn, and
also work knowledge graph
from Office 365 Dynamics.
Now imagine that all our
customers and partners,
they can combine
Microsoft Graphs with their own
business data and knowledge
about their own users to view
the incredible AI applications
for their customers, for
the employees, and
for their business.
So we feel very, very excited
about the opportunities there
that we can work together.
And one particularly unique
thing about Microsoft is that
we have worked long and
hard to bring many of
these graphs together,
contained within a compliance
boundary that actually conforms
to our privacy compliance and
also data policies.
That's very,
very important to enterprises.
So those investments really
underscore what we have
been doing in Microsoft AI
in the research,
those five things actually
I talked to you today.
I just want to finish
my presentation by
mentioning some
also important and
exciting topics nowadays as
people talk about AI development
in partnership in society and
also in ethics.
So as we embrace
this AI frontier
we have to acknowledge that you
know concerns about AI do exist.
And it's actually important that
we have some universal design
principles and values that
help guide our thinking,
our design, and development.
At Microsoft,
we take an ethical approach to
AI design sincerely and
seriously.
Our principle approach is
actually very critical.
We do these things
thoughtfully and
in a trustworthy way both inside
the Microsoft and also outside.
For example,
internally we have organized
an advisory committee
that helps ensure
the hereins of this principles
in our own AI development.
And externally, we recognize
that we cannot do that alone.
So we co-founded the Partnership
on AI just over a year ago.
This is actually a nonprofit
organization where you see many
leading tech companies and
academia, civil societies, and
many, many nonprofit
organizations,
who actually care about
the future of AI development.
So this is actually set up
to study, formulate, and
share the best practices on
AI technology for all of us.
So we also believe that we need
to give back as we develop AI.
So I'd like to take this
opportunity to thank iNaturalist
who is the great partner in
our AI for Earth program.
They are here today.
I encourage you to stop by
their booths to talk to them,
what they do for our society.
And finally, I would say, as the
first generation to live with
AI, we play a very unique
role in shaping the future.
As we will do so,
that is actually thoughtful.
That is really our number
one focus in Microsoft.
So there's a lot we don't really
know about the AIC impact yet.
But we do know is that AI
has a lot of potential
to really improve lives.
And it's already happening now.
So let me share a story with you
about how AI has given voices to
those who otherwise
would have had none.
[MUSIC]
>> SwiftKey Symbols is a
communication app for people who
are nonverbal and it supports
them in expressing themselves.
>> Merlin, my youngest brother,
has low functioning autism.
He finds it difficult
to communicate and
can get very upset if he can't
make himself understood.
I took what we used at home with
some symbols that my mom would
print out, laminate, cut out and
stick velcro on, put them into
folders and I just thought
I could make that easier.
If we did it on an app,
be more fun for Rowan
because he loves technology.
>> The underlying AI technology
which SwiftKey symbols uses,
is the same technology which
powers the SwiftKey keyboards.
We use AI technology to be
able to learn from the user's
behavior, to see what they
like to use in terms of
their own style of language, to
predict what's gonna come next.
>> It works by having a library
of symbols that you can pick and
choose to build your sentence.
And each symbol has a word
associated with it.
And we use Swift Key AI
predictive technology to learn
what you've used previously,
sentences that you've previously
built and then we surface what
word you might want next, and
what symbol you might want next,
to build your sentence.
>> I want cheese please, Kate.
>> Ahh, wow!
>> We developed it
alongside Riverside School,
which is a school specializing
in learning difficulties.
>> To be able to express what
they want without prompting,
is a really big thing.
>> We have so many pupils
who are nonverbal but
still have so much to say.
>> I think AI can just make
everything in life more
efficient, so
you can enjoy life to the max.
>> There's no better feeling
than to hear a child say
something that they've
wanted to say,
and the look on their face after
they've been able to say it.
You can't really beat that,
because that's them expressing
themselves, and that's really
what you want from them.
>> It's joyous.
I don't think I can think
of a better word for it.
It's complete joy and
celebration.
[MUSIC]
>> Well done, Tyree.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> It's really an incredible
time working on AI and to use AI
to improve our human ingenuity.
>> And we're very excited
to work on those
things at Microsoft.
Thank you very much again for
joining us today.
Please, if you have time,
hang on here,
check out all the booths.
Thank you very much.